many individuals who are pursuing
careers as actors are only known for
their time in the spotlight
not the dark and challenging road to get
there have you ever wondered if some of
your favorite actors were almost
overcome by the treacherous path to fame
i'm not ready for this
one of the freshest faces in hollywood
millie bobby brown has us all wondering
how exactly did she get where she is
today on one episode of the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon
millie confessed that she almost quit
acting completely after being rejected
from a role on game of thrones i then
auditioned for game of thrones and i got
a nose
as a last-ditch effort she tried out for
a netflix show which is now known as
stranger things
and has since made it big as an actress
with stranger things moving on to a
fourth season
known for her role of hermione in the
harry potter series and as belle in
beauty and the beast
emma watson almost gave up on her acting
career after getting lots of fame and
attention from her childhood career in
harry potter
she felt as though she could not fill
the traditional expectations of an
actress but later realized the potential
this career would give her to be a
platform for female empowerment
that felt good not good brilliant
best known for her role as wonder woman
in the modern adaptation of the comic
gal also had a challenging path to
success as she emigrated from israel
she found a decent outlet to success
through her role as giselle in one of
the fast and furious films
but it did not create a big enough
splash in the industry to grant her a
long-term career
after securing her role as wonder woman
in the 2017 film her career got a whole
bunch brighter
and so did her outlook on her passion
stay here
i'll go ahead the main stars of the
twilight franchise
almost didn't make it to or past their
fantastical roles as vampire lovers
okay i want to negotiate my own
condition
kristen stewart's early acting career
involved driving around los angeles from
audition to audition with rejection
present at nearly everyone
her anxiety around the audition process
didn't make this long line of refusal
any easier
she decided to continue on to her final
audition for the safety of objects
and finally landed a role kristen
stewart's co-worker robert pattinson had
a lot of trouble finding roles in the
entertainment industry
after his role in harry potter and the
goblet of fire as cedric diggory
pattinson's talent agent began
encouraging him to bring a guitar with
him to auditions which perplexed the
filmmakers and sent his confidence into
the gutter
he even called his parents after the
audition and told them he was
considering ditching the career
until he got a call the next day telling
him he'd landed the role
another victim of the relentless
rejection that is ever present in the
acting market henry cavill
was rejected so many times before being
hired for the witcher and superman that
he was very close to quitting acting
completely and joining the army
the superman star was quoted saying
there were plenty of times i thought it
wouldn't happen
at one stage i was like if this next
movie doesn't do well then i'm out
i'm going to join the armed forces
another now famous actor bradley cooper
almost didn't make it big cooper
struggled with mental health issues
during his rise to fame
including a bad bout of depression which
led him to struggles in finding his
footing as an actor
then dealing with the hardships of a
torn achilles and addiction struggles
cooper made it back to the spotlight
with wedding crashers
several cast members from the avengers
franchise nearly didn't make it to the
place where they are today
in their careers mark ruffalo famous for
his roles in avengers end game captain
marvel
and zodiac tried out for nearly 1 000
roles before landing anything major in
his youth yeah it was
uh it was tough as someone who also has
a leading role in various avengers films
scarlett hated the way in which
hollywood hyper-sexualized her
and wanted a break from the reductive
portrayal and objectification
but she claims now that she's grateful
for never quitting as
now she states there's so many wonderful
opportunities for women of every age to
play all different types of people
god i get emails from a raccoon so
nothing sounds crazy anymore
a bit unlike the rest of the actors and
actresses featured here
elizabeth olsen feared fame after her
older twin sisters mary kate and ashley
olson
had garnered much attention throughout
their childhood for their roles on full
house
you like work yeah elizabeth found this
type of attention
toxic and damaging she almost didn't
enter the industry out of fear of the
effects of fame and dealing with an
eating disorder
what does that mean
another avengers star chris hemsworth
nearly quit acting after failing to find
a job after his work in star trek
he thought extensively about packing up
and moving back home to australia
but he kept persevering nonetheless the
actor secured his role in the horror
film the cabin in the woods
keeping him involved in the
entertainment industry long enough for
him to find his upcoming character thor
in the avengers franchise can you
imagine anyone else playing for
thank goodness chris didn't give up kind
of an angry sludge
sort of a thing so someone's going to
amend that
and stop saying that after being in the
entertainment industry for many years
before landing a career-making role
melissa mccarthy vowed that she would
quit acting for good if she didn't get a
job that she was passionate about and
that could give her some security by the
time she turned 30.
that's me luckily on her 30th birthday
she heard back that she had gotten the
role of sookie on the upcoming series
gilmore girls
we're glad she stuck with it as this
character was a pivotal role in making
gilmore girls what we know today
and led melissa to an extremely
successful career in tv and film
another female avengers actress free
larsen almost didn't make it to where
she is today
she did some acting as a child but found
it difficult to continue on with her
career as she grew older
larson tried out for the united states
of tara television series
initially being rejected but finally
getting a call back that told her she
was being recast as one of the series
characters
this gave her the motivation to continue
on to the roles we know her for today
including captain marvel hi i'm
peter parker hey peter parker this
actress failed to find a gig for nearly
two years
are you just biting your time with me
deciding to switch to a career in
interior design instead
to make ends meet i want to be a person
who has a life and who acts
she was frustrated with the lack of
roles that were more meaningful and
substantive for women
she admitted to vogue magazine it was
confusing i got a lot of plaudits and it
didn't translate into more work
two years of not working was brutal it
was grim
i was very hurt best known for his role
as severus snape in the harry potter
franchise
and despite this undeniable success alan
rickman almost gave up on his career
before he finished working on the series
he found his role as snape to be a
rather static one and had to be
persuaded into finishing the movie
franchise as said character
facing a difficult time securing roles
in hollywood because of her unique
features
naturally red hair inherent shy attitude
and her mistrust of the industry's
sexism
jessica chastain found success for the
first time in her role in the help
[Laughter]
where she played celia foote we now know
her for her roles in films like
interstellar
zero dark 30 and the tree of life thank
goodness she didn't quit before making
these iconic films
initially working as a high school drama
teacher in missouri after graduating
college
jon hamm then decided to take up a
career in acting
his entrance into the industry was
undeniably rough as he was not able to
secure
a bigger role throughout much of his
adulthood he finally scored the role of
don draper on mad men when he was 36
finally giving him the career he'd
always dreamed of
never scoring a big role until he worked
on pulp fiction in the 1990s
this is a tasty burger samuel l jackson
started off on a pessimistic foot
at this point in his life he was 45
years old after having searched for many
years for a role big
enough to lead to his overall success
and only getting much more minor roles
pulp fiction helped rocket him to the
level of fame he is at today
working as a full-time carpenter until
he was in his mid-30s
harrison ford was recruited by george
lucas to act in various star wars films
he didn't even enter the entertainment
industry until he was 35 years old
this struggle to find work is exemplary
of the intense age limits that hollywood
expects its workers to unfairly adhere
to
well that's the real trick isn't it
after struggling with being typecast for
all of his career
starting with the wire and all my
children michael b jordan was very
frustrated with the reductive view of
him as an actor
leading to his desire to drop out of the
industry completely
he was able to find more meaningful
roles as his career progressed
eventually showing up in fruitvale
station and later black panther
how might the challenges that these
actors faced have shaped their careers
take a look at the work they've been
involved in and see for yourself if
these actors have been shaped by their
difficult paths to success
let us know what you think in the
comment section below thanks for
watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content about your favorite tv shows and
movies
we'll see you next time